Hey, Leute, ach come on, ey, ohne Scheiss, Mann. Du kannst nicht jetzt jedes Mal wegen dem Scheisskopfhörer rummeckern. Doch, doch, das ist mein neuer Person. So neu ist das nicht, dass du dich wegen Kleinigkeiten aufregst. Hattest du den auch mal wieder Fallschirm aufgesetzt, ob dann das andere Ohr kaputt ist? Vielleicht liegt es dir wirklich an deinem Ohr. Stefan, geh zum Arzt! Ich habe meine Ohren, meine Ohren habe ich nichts zu beklagen. So, das ist immer noch schlecht. Meinst du, Hals, Nasen, Ohren, Ärzte werden sich irgendwann erweitern? Dass sie sagen, so Hals, Nasen, Ohren und so schläfen. Also, dass man so... Hals, Nasen, Ohren, Augenbrauen, Arzt. Wir haben zu wenig zu tun. Die sitzen alle rum und sagen, ach ja, die Leute benutzen ihren Hals. Wir hätten das Knie noch mit reinnehmen sollen. Rückblickend hätten wir das noch mit reinnehmen sollen. Viele haben Knieprobleme. Zumindest mal Nacken. Hals, aber nicht Nacken. Du gehst zum Nackenarzt und er sagt, nee. Das Ding ist, Orthopäden sind ja immer voll. Ich meine Meinung nach haben die zu viele Organe mit reingenommen. Mit Organe meine ich auch alles andere, was keine Organe sind. Also Knochengedöns und so, und so Physiotherapeuten-Quack. Da denke ich mir auch, warum machen die nicht anders als die Hals-Nasen-Ohren-Erste und sagen so minus ... Also, alles ausser Rücken. Wir sind Orthopädie nur ohne Rücken. Das fände ich, glaube ich, clever. Das war das Thema auch Lehrer. Also, du plädierst für eine neue Mischung der Organe und der Zuständigkeiten im medizinischen Bereich. Auf jeden Fall. Das ist das, was ich gesagt habe, nur viel schöner ausgedrückt. Das kann nur einer, der gegenüber von mir sitzt. Stefan Tietze. Florentin Will. Boah, ich habe echt heute wenig geschlafen. Also, wir müssen das so sagen, heute wird es so ein bisschen so eine Laidback-Folge. Wir sind beide massiv schlecht gelaunt. Also wirklich, also wir saßen uns jetzt schon eine Stunde lang gegenüber mit diesen gekräuselten Stirn.
Wenn man so zwischen den Augenbrauen hat, haben sich schon so, auch jetzt, obwohl wir normal gucken, sind immer noch die Falten zu sehen, weil die so lange so waren, die Augenbrauen nur gerunzelt.
Ne, so saßen wir uns gegenüber, wir sind beide müde, hüsterlich, krank, heiser, was auch nervig ist, wenn man weiß, man redet eine Stunde.
Ey, ich glaube, ich habe noch nie eine Nacht so schlecht organisiert wie die heutige Nacht. Es war einfach von vorne bis hinten eine logistische Katastrophe. Jetzt stellen Sie sich Fragen bei mir, jemandem, der seine Nacht nicht organisieren muss, weil es eine Nacht ist, wo per se nichts passiert. Per Definition passiert nachts nichts. Nee, Nacht ist nicht gleich Nacht. Nichts ist geiler als eine gut organisierte Nacht. Heißt, du weißt genau, wie lange du schlafen musst, du gehst genau in dem Moment ins Bett, in dem du noch so oh, ich hab noch 20 Minuten, um noch was zu lesen und dann bin ich genau perfekt müde, um einzuschlafen. Und das hinzukriegen ist sehr schwer. Bei mir war es so, ich hab irgendwie nachts eine Mail bekommen, so hey, übrigens, du musst morgen um 10 hier sein, da war es 1 Uhr nachts und meine Waschmaschine läuft noch drei Stunden lang. Weil ich dachte, ich müsste später kommen. Das heißt, ich dachte mir, fuck, ich muss meine Waschmaschine noch abwarten und kann dann frühestens um vier ins Bett gehen. Weil aber auch deine Wäschesituation ungeordnet ist. Die ist vielleicht nicht richtig organisiert, weil du nämlich die Wäsche brauchst, du warst angewiesen auf die Wäsche, die fertig wird. Klar, da kommt dann alles zusammen, aber dann dachte ich mir, okay, ich habe jetzt noch drei Stunden, kann ich ja noch eine Mate trinken. Oh nein. Trinkt die Mate, Koffein strömt durch mein Blut und selbst um vier Uhr nachts liege ich im Bett, falschrum, auf dem Kopfstand liege ich im Bett und denke mir, okay, ich kann nicht schlafen. Und dann liegst du halt noch mal drei Stunden wach, dann machst du dir oh fuck, wenn ich jetzt nicht schlafe, dann bin ich schlecht drauf und dann machst du dir wieder selber Vorwürfe und dann kommst du nicht mehr raus und dann hast du eh verloren. Es müsste echt einfach so ein Aufgeben-Button geben.
Es ist so ein Aufgeben-Button.
In den Spielen, ich bin jemand, der gerne aufgibt.
Der irgendwie so sagt, der auch mal sagt, keine Ahnung, dann baue ich meine Felder, meine Häuser und dann passt da was nicht zusammen.
Ich gebe sofort auf.
Einfach, ich gebe sofort auf.
Und das müsste es im Leben auch geben, dass man einfach sagt, nee, weißt du, heute, ich finde sowieso, das Leben sollte viel mehr Videospiel-esker werden. Zu sagen so, jeder hat einen Tag im Jahr, wo Dinge nur die Hälfte kosten.
So wie so ein Trank. So ein Trank, den du in einem Videospiel bekommst, den du nur einmal bekommst und alle Gegner machen nur noch halb so viel Schaden.
So etwas müsste es im Leben geben.
Ja, und eine klarere Anzeige, wann man sein Ziel erreicht hat.
Du musst noch so und so viele Bananen sammeln, dann kannst du den Gorilla besuchen. Endlich den Gorilla-Boss. Und auch diese Händler, dass alle neben dem Händler stehen, so im Kreis, und alle können mit ihm sprechen. Dass er diese Multitasking-fähig ist, dass er mit jedem so handeln kann gleichzeitig. Der MMORPG-Händler, den gibt's im echten Leben nicht. Auch nervig. Sidequests, klassische Sidequests, gut organisiert, auch mal wegdrücken, einmal so ein Sidequest wegdrücken, wo man sagt, jetzt Friseurtermin, nein! Einfach mal weg mit so Sidequests. Ja. Ist deine Itemtasche voll? Absolut voll. Ey, ich hab vor allem die Vordertasche. Ich weiß nicht, wie du mit Schlüsseln umgehst, aber meine Schlüsselsituation ist katastrophal. Auch ein klassisches Videospielproblem. Zwar, ich habe alle Schlüssel in meinem Rucksack. Mal wohin mit den Schlüsseln? Ich bin kein Fan vom Schlüsselbund, weil ich möchte wenig Dinge in meiner Hose haben. Du machst es dir aber auch schwer. Du hast immer Probleme, wo man denkt, okay, ich verstehe das Problem, aber dann merkt man, dann fragt man mal nach, woher kommt denn das Problem, wo rührt denn das Problem her? Und man stößt bei dir immer, je tiefer man gräbt, auf eine komische Regel, die einfach dir das Leben selber zur Hölle macht. Du legst dir die Stolpersteine selber hinweg. Du bist angenommen, stell dich mal Flo und dich auf so einem Feld vor, er hat ganz viele so Minen in der Hand und dann hat er die einmal, macht er die Arme so auf und schmeißt alle Minen um sich rum. Das ist so ungefähr dein psychischer Zustand, du kommst einfach da nicht raus, von diesem Feld, da bist du verloren, da wirst du alleine verenden. Weil ohne Scheiß, was hast du gegen Schlüsselbund, was hast du gegen Betten? Alle haben Betten, akzeptiere das Konzept des Bettes, akzeptiere das Konzept des Schlüsselbundes, da haben sie da Gedanken gemacht, das ist nicht schlecht. Naja, das Problem ist, ich bin sehr unflexibel und man fängt, ich bin in dieses Problem reingewachsen. Man fängt an, man ist ein Kind, man ist glücklich, man hat keine Schlüssel. Als Kind hat man keine Schlüssel. Aber Schlüsselbünde. Ich hatte ganz viele diese Ringe, aber keine Schlüssel. Mega nervig. Und dann wo man dann so ganz viele so, du hast dann den Alf, den Alf-Kreisel, die Lego-Figur, du hast dann ganz viele Schlüsselanhänger, aber keinen Schlüssel. Und du hast einen Schlüssel zu deinem Poesiealbum, den eh keinen interessiert. Kinder kriegen zu viel Schlüsselanhänger. Ja. Es sind die Leute, die am wenigsten Schlüssel haben, denen gibt man die meisten Schlüsselanhänger. Star Wars, Pokémon, alles voll. Jetzt gerade Weihnachten und Thema Geschenke kommt wieder auf. Ich würde einem Menschen niemals einen Schlüsselanhänger denken. Weil ich würde mir denken, wenn dieser Mensch Schlüsselanhänger mag, hat er schon einen. Und wenn er schon einen hat, braucht er keinen zweiten. Wieder so eine Regel, alle sind sauer, weil Florentin Will nichts Leuten zu Weihnachten schenkt. Reden wir mal ein bisschen tiefer, kommt heraus, dass er diese Regel für sich entwickelt hat, dass man Leuten nur das schenkt, was sie schon besitzen. Weil das ist in der Regel das, was sie am meisten brauchen. Deswegen ist die Regel, dass du Weihnachten furchtbar findest. Ich glaube, ich habe vor zwei Jahren, und so lange gibt es den Podcast schon, vor zwei Jahren habe ich eine Empfehlung gemacht, was man Menschen zu Weihnachten schenken kann. Und zwar habe ich gesagt, schenkt Menschen gute Bettwäsche, qualitativ hochwertige Bettwäsche, weil das sind Sachen, für die gibt man selber ungern Geld aus. Man ist eingezogen, man hat bei Ikea sich irgendwie für so 12,99 mal so Bettwäsche geholt, aber es lohnt sich, aber man würde selber, weil das ist dann irgendwie so Luxus, und wenn du dir teure Bettwäsche kaufst, dann brauchst du auch teure Handtücher, dann brauchst du auch teure Kleidung, dann brauchst du auch teure Vorhänge, das wird sehr schnell sehr teuer, deswegen machst du es selber nicht, aber als Geschenker sagt man, als Geschenker, naja, ich sag mal, hast du eine Grenze, du hast eine Budgetgrenze auf jeden Fall, aber Geschmacksfrage, weil ich habe keine noch, ich finde selten Bettwäsche, die mir gefällt, Deswegen ganz schlichte Ich finde die schlechteste Bettwäsche, man findet selten, man hat auch schlechte Bettwäsche. Es ist immer kariert, Blümchen, Hello Kitty drauf. Ganz schlicht, ich empfehle Marco Polo an der Stelle, die haben eine gute Qualität, aber ich habe nämlich mal im Podcast gesagt, schenkt Leuten teure Bettwäsche und habe von mehreren Leuten unabhängig davon dafür richtig auf die Fresse bekommen und hat gesagt, nein, du musst das zurückziehen, mach das auf gar keinen Fall, du wirst ganz viel Unheil und Leid anrichten, empfiehlt das Leuten auf gar keinen Fall, ich möchte mich bei allen entschuldigen, die sich diesen Tipp zu Herzen genommen haben und eine böse Überraschung und ein böses Erwachen hatten am nächsten Tag. Was war das Erwachen? Bettwäsche. Anscheinend ist es eine sehr große Geschmackssache, irgendwie ist es nicht, du hast völlig recht Leute verbinden sehr viel mit ihrer Bettwäsche, es ist ein sehr intimes Objekt, vielleicht eher Bettlaken. Aber auch da die Farbe. Welche Farbe? Ich trau es wenigstens den ganzen Tritt zurückzugehen und zu sagen, okay, ich überdenke mein Konzept noch mal, dass du selbst da sagst, okay, du willst von dem Konzept Bett abrücken, so ein bisschen. Sofa-Decke vielleicht, die werden schnell dreck dreckig und dann muss man die waschen, aber dann werden die so fusselig. Sofa-Decke ist auch nicht so ganz intim wie ein Bett. Ich will auch nicht in dem Geschenk schlafen. Das ist das Geschenk, was ich immer von meiner Tante bekomme, wo das Gesicht meiner Cousine drauf ist. Ich will nicht das Geschenk von jemandem die ganze Zeit um einen Rum haben, in den unangenehmsten Situationen. Ich will nicht in Florentins Geschenk schlafen. Schlafsack ist doch das schlimmste Geschenk. Ich will nicht in Florentins ehemaligen Besitz schlafen. An der Stelle auch mal ein Shoutout an alle Frauen, die Stefan zu sich nach Hause mitgebracht haben und die dann auf dem Kopfkissen schlafen musste, auf dem das Gesicht der zwölfjährigen Cousine von Stefan abgebildet ist. Ich habe ich ein sehr lustiges Bild gesehen von einem Kopfkissenüberzug,
wo so ein kleines Bärchen drauf war.
Und abgebildet war so ein kleiner Junge, der auf dem Bärchenkissen schläft,
so als Werbung für dieses Kissen.
Und er hat immer dieses Kissen bestellt und stellt sich raus,
der Junge ist auch auf dem Bärchenkissen.
Und dann liegst du auf einem Jungen, der auf einem Bärchenkopfkissen liegt.
Oh nein, das pädophilen Wunderland.
Das Beste ist bei Kissen, wenn man nicht wie ich jeden Morgen die Kissen aufschüttelt, werden die ja so faltig. So ein Bär sieht dann irgendwann nicht mehr aus wie ein Bär, sondern wie ein Horrorbär, weil so die Augen immer näher zum Mund kommen und irgendwann ist das so eine furchtbare Horror-Kreatur. Also wie Kerzen, wenn man so eine Kerze gibt es eigentlich so eine Art Skulpturenkerzen, die man so 3-D-Druckermässig von sich selbst anfertigen kann? Irgendwann steht der Kopf in Flammen oder ist langsam den Augen weg. Ja, das ist ganz grusslich, du hast dann irgendwie so Snoopy-Kopf als Kerze, aber dann zündest du den an und dann hat der so eine komplett dämonische Fratze irgendwann. Und dann haben die Kinder Angst vor dem. Übrigens, einer der erfolgreichsten Tweets im Moment, man sollte Trump doch bitte sagen, man will eine Statue von ihm anfertigen, um ihn dann 3D zu scannen, aber in Wirklichkeit macht man Gehirn-MRT, um zu gucken, was da falsch gelaufen ist. Das ist gerade ein sehr erfolgreicher Tweet. Ich finde das nicht schlecht. Pranks auf ein neues Level heben. Der Beruf des Bildhauers stirbt aus, oder? Ja. Also völlig, oder? Ja. Ich meine, irgendwann Grabsteine kannst du dann so ein PDF runterladen und dann drückt der den Grabstein aus. Stein ist glaube ich noch was anderes, weil da musst du vorsichtig sein. Warum, wenn du so Laserroboter hast, die das dann weglasern? Ich glaube nicht, alle Steine akzeptieren Laser. Meine Steine sagen, nope, nicht mit mir. Ich bin Granit und ich reagiere ganz empfindlich auf Wärme. So klingt Granit für dich. Sorry. Ja, Granit ist ein bisschen sassy, so ein bisschen, ähm, ich hab mir das ein bisschen anders vorgestellt. Sorry, ähm, nein, danke. Laser, nein, nicht in mir, okay? Wie ist Marmor? Marmor ist so ein gestandener, alter, so ein Earl.
So ein ... ein bisschen hochgestochen,
mit so einem Monokel noch im Auge.
Ähm, hallo, mein Name ist Marmor.
Und er hat diese lächerlich hohe Fistelstimme.
Und er trinkt Tee, das ist Marmor für mich.
Sehr konkrete Vorstellung.
Schiefer, Punk.
Schiefer ist ein Crazy-Punk.
Immer laut, zu laut. Ist da eine Sitcom in Planung? Rolling Rocks? Rock Me? Sowas in der Richtung? Steine, die halt so wirklich so bestehen daneben stehen? Stone Me One More Time? Stonefeld? Die zustimmende Hupe. Wir nehmen heute an der Donau auf und hier fahren einige Schiffe vorbei, die uns immer herzlich grüssen und wir winken auch immer. Ich glaube, wir sind ein bisschen im Weg mit unserem kleinen Boot, aber ansonsten haben wir hier eine schöne Atmosphäre. Ein Freund aus der Heimat wohnt direkt an der Autobahn und er hat ein Riesengrundstück, weil seine Eltern sind Jäger und so ein Kram und die sind auf dem Bauernhof. es ist ein riesen Grundstück, dass bis an die Autobahn, die A1 geht, eine sehr grosse Autobahn, wie ich nun mal schon sagen, und dann kann man halt daran, sich direkt daneben stehen, weil das Grundstück dahingeht und man kann halt die Lkw immer zum Hupen bringen, indem man halt diese, ich nenne sie mal, Bizeps-Trainiergeste macht und dann zweimal runter geht und dann hupen die. Manche sind aber extrem sauer und nach mindestens zehn Minuten kommt die Polizei auch an, weil Leute besorgt anrufen, dass Leute an der Autobahn stehen. Das ist immer so. Jedes Mal, wenn wir da sind, rufen Leute bei der Polizei an und sagen, da stehen Leute an der Autobahn, dann kommt die Polizei an, sagt, hey, wir müssen kurz hier hinkommen, weil Leute besorgt angerufen haben, ciao, dann fahren die wieder. Ich stand letztens mindestens eine Stunde irgendwie auf der Bahnstrecke, bin mit dem Zug
gefahren, wegen Polizeieinsatz,
wegen Personen im Gleis.
Im Gleis. Und ich weiß immer nicht, ist das Code
für Selbstmordversuch?
Oder sind es einfach
Kinder, die auf dem Gleis spielen und wo dann die
Polizei halt einfach, laufen die
die Strecke ab oder fahren die dann
oder haben die dann so diese Pumpwägen
aus diesen Westernfilmen mit so einem Blaulicht oben drauf, weil du kannst dich ja nicht schnell bewegen, auch wenn du jetzt nicht einen Zug hast. Wahnsinnig anstrengend. Nee, ich, die brauchen eine Sirene gar nicht mehr machen. Könnt ihr bitte vom Gleis gehen? In meiner Theorie haben die Laser. Und am Ende, also der Zug schickt einen Laser und am Ende der andere Zug, der davor irgendwo eine Million geht ja gar nicht, weil das biegt sich ja auch immer. Vor allem Indianer, die können doch an den Gleisen hören, ob ein Zug kommt, weil das so ganz fein die Vibration überträgt. Ich glaube nicht, weil die super Gehör haben. Aber kann man das nicht umgekehrt auch machen,
dass man ein Mikrofon an die Gleise
anschließt und dann tönt es
über die ganzen Gleise, dass man sagt,
hallo, kann ich bitte weggehen und dann hört man das
über die ganzen Gleise. Erstmal glaube ich, ist das sehr gut Video überwacht,
die Hotspots, diese Suizid-Hotspots.
Keinste nicht so tausend Kilometer Video überwacht.
Die Suizid-Hotspots, die Highlights.
Die Highlights des guten Geschmacks
für Selbstmörder, glaube ich,
wo man gut auf die Gleise gehen kann.
Das ist, glaube ich, einigermaßen Video überwacht.
Und dann, wo man gut auf die Gleise gehen kann. Das ist, glaube ich, einigermaßen videoüberwacht. Und dann, glaube ich, hast du wirklich einfach so Bewegungssensoren. Bist du mal an einem Gleis entlang gelaufen? Nee, nee, nee, nee. Bei uns in der Schulzeit ist mal der Zug ausgefallen und ein Freund von mir und ich, wir haben uns entschieden, aus der Nachbarstadt in unsere Heimatstadt zu laufen auf den Gleisen, auf den S-Bahn-Gleisen. Wow, du bist ein Problem. Du bist wirklich, du bist das Problem. Ja, aber da ist der Zug ausgefallen, das war dann irgendwie Signalstörung oder alles kaputt und den Rest des Tages fallen alle Züge aus. Und wir so, gut, wir können jetzt halt auf dem Bus warten oder wir laufen halt eine Stunde nach Hause. Und vor allem, das war sehr interessant, weil wir fahren ja, ja gut, mit der S-Bahn dauert das so drei Minuten, wie lange dauert das zu Fuß? Zehn Minuten? Nee, eineinhalb Stunden. Sind eineinhalb Stunden gelaufen, war viel zu spät, kam viel zu spät, habe Riesenärger bekommen. Wir haben einen toten Hund gefunden, neben den Gleisen, wo wir auch nicht wissen, wie das passiert ist. Wir haben einen Sitz, einen S-Bahn-Sitz gefunden, den jemand anscheinend abmontiert hat. Oh, ein S-Bahnsitz. Ein S-Bahnsitz. S-Bahnsitz. Ein S-Bahnsitz.
Anscheinend hat während der Fahrt jemand den S-Bahnsitz abmontiert und aus dem Fenster geworfen. Ey, wütend. Ich weiß nicht, wie das eskalieren kann. Bahn zu spät. Wir haben ganz viele verschiedene Sachen, wir haben sogar Muscheln gefunden. Also ganz strange, das ist eine Art Strache. Das ist eine Parallelwelt. Ey, Gleise ist wirklich ganz verrückt. Das typische I am Legend Bild, dieses, der einzige Mensch auf der Erde, ich will andern auf Gleisen rumgehen, das ist, wo du sonst nicht sein kannst, auf Gleisen rumgehen, das ist das Ding. Ich habe neulich so ein Fahrzeug gesehen, jeder kennt ja diese komischen zylinderförmigen Fahrzeuge, wo unten diese Wischer dran sind, diese drehbaren Wischer, diese Zahnbürstenartigen Dinge, die am Rand langfahren und dann die Straße, naja, sauber machen. Tatsächlich ist es hinter dem Fahrzeug ähnlich dreckig wie vor dem Fahrzeug, alles ganz strange. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was hinten in diesem Tankwagenartigen Dingen drin ist. Ich glaube, die suchen was. Die sammeln alles ein, scannen das und tun es wieder raus. Die suchen einen Schlüssel oder sowas. Und diese Maschinen fahren durch die Stadt und scannen einfach nur und tasten die ganze Strasse ab. Was ist denn vor allem drin? Was ist in diesem Wasser? Ist das Wasser drin? Aber die pusten die nicht nur und haben die nicht diese Hydro-Luft? Ich verstehe das nicht. Jedenfalls, Fakt ist, die können auf Gleise fahren, ihre Reifen hochfahren, unten drunter kommen S-Bahn-Dinger zum Vorschein, und die können auf den Gleisen fahren. Wo ich mir denke, holy shit, Fahrzeuge zu Ende gedacht. Geil, das finde ich gut. Ein Amphibienfahrzeug in der Hinsicht, dass es auch auf Gleisen fahren kann. Das ist ja geil. Ein ambivalentes Fahrzeug. Ja, das ist nicht schlecht. Ich wohne ja direkt neben dem Bahnhof, und da kriege ich dann irgendwie alle paar Wochen so einen Zettel in den Briefkasten, wo auf der Bahn steht, hey, passen Sie auf, Bauarbeiten am Bahnhof, irgendwie die Nacht wird sehr laut. Da kriege ich regelmäßig so einen Hinweis. An die Tür geklebt. In den Briefkasten, anscheinend haben die so einen Radius um den Bahnhof rum, und immer wenn da was ist ist, kriegen alle dann Brief. Geile Wohngegend. Ich finde es interessant, weil ich fühle mich irgendwie wichtig, so von wegen so Oh, danke, dass sie Bescheid sagen. Und dann lege ich halt meine Hausparty an einen anderen Termin, dass es dann nicht so laut ist. Warum? Damit man nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwie auf der einen Seite Scooter und auf der anderen Seite Eeeeee, Dede, Dede, weil die dann irgendwas absägen oder sowas. Nee, weil die einen Typen engagieren, der Sägegeräusche macht. So. Aber dann sagen die dir Bescheid. Ja, und dann sagen die, hey, es wird laut, und ich so, kann ich was dagegen machen? Nein, es wird nur laut. Aber es ist besser, es ist wirklich besser, wenn man weiß, dass es schlimm wird. Du kannst planen, wo wir bei der Planung wären. Du bist darauf vorbereitet, was passiert und kannst dich dann einstellen auf die Situation. Ich glaube, alles ist besser mit Ankündigung. Gibt es in Köln? Gestern bin ich zu lang gelaufen und waren da Stolpersteine. Moment, du bist zu lang gelaufen? Ich bin so lang gelaufen. Mit Schienen, Langlauf oder was? Ich bin so da lang gelaufen. Okay, das ist eine normale Rede, wenn du ums Sohn. Du bist spieren gegangen, oder was? Ich bin da so lang gelaufen, durch Köln, am Dom. Ich bin am Dom lang gelaufen, weil da so ein Fotoladen war. Ich wollte Vogtfotos entwickeln lassen. Okay, die Geschichte entwickelt sich. Tatsächlich wollte ich Fotos entwickeln lassen, und dann ist im Dom, also halb im Dom drangebaut, so ein Touriladen, wo man die entwickeln lassen kann. Ja, wo die zerbombt wurden, wo Bilder sind, wie Köln aussah, als sie bombardiert wurden. Fun Fact, nicht so gut. Es sah nicht so gut aus. Ja, aber der Dom hat überlebt. Er hat überlebt. Auch straight. Haben die rumgebombt, haben die gesagt, Respekt, große Kirche, die wollen wir stehen lassen. Die haben dann aktiv drum herum gebombt, oder? Das ist eine interessante Frage. Oder hat sie wie ein Wunder überlebt? Nee, nicht wie ein Wunder. Ich weiß nicht, ob man so präzise bombardieren kann. Also ich glaube, die bombardieren einfach die gesamte Stadt. Also wenn du jetzt nicht wirklich punktuell Sachen wie Bahnhöfe oder Brücken bombardieren willst, ich glaube, wenn du eine Stadt bombardierst, ist es so eher einfach so. Das ist schon hart, das ist schon auch der letzte Weg irgendwie. Und es hat nicht so viel gebracht, das wusste Churchill aber, ist ein anderes Thema. Aber es ist eine interessante Geschichte. Tatsächlich waren dann da, ich fange mal an meine Bullshit-Geschichte zu machen, wo ihr nichts lernt und nichts mitnehmen könnt, vielleicht ein bisschen lacht. Naja, und dann habe ich da Stolpersteine gesehen und das letztliche bezeichnet man einfach, dass man ausgetauschte Pflastersteine. Sind die aus Gold? Ich weiß es nicht. Ist das das Nazi-Gold? Da waren die auch Gold und dann steht halt jüdische Namen drin und die sind Familienverschwunden. verschwunden. Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, ist das Prinzip Stolperstein? Die Idee ist sehr gut, das Konzept ist sehr gut, aber macht es doch noch mehr zu Stolpersteinen. Weil wie gut wäre denn auch das Holocaust-Denkmal subtiler, wenn man denkt, zunächst man geht auf dem normalen Weg und geht nochmal da lang und plötzlich stoppert man wirklich, weil plötzlich einfach so ein Stein rausragt leicht und denkt man, okay, was war das, okay, strange, geht weiter und dann häufen sich diese Steine, wo man aus Versehen immer drüber läuft. Und es entwickelt sich so, für Touristen, die dann einfach aus Versehen da lang gehen, die stolpern einander rum und es ist so Struggeln und von außen kannst du einfach immer filmen und siehst halt Leute, die da sind rum. Ich glaube, es wird irgendwann komplex, wenn du ein Denkmal brauchst für die Leute, die wegen des Holocaust-Denkmals gestorben sind, die gestürzt und sich das Genick gebrochen haben, wenn du dafür dann wieder ein Denkmal brauchst und wieder Stolpersteine. Aber auf der anderen Seite, viele sagen es immer so, ja, Juden, Juden, Juden, war schon schlimm, aber was ist denn mit den ganzen anderen Völkermorden der Geschichte, mit den ganzen anderen Gräueltaten? Ich bin einfach dafür, auch für alle anderen deportierten und vernichteten Völker und Rassen auch Stolpersteine zu machen. Einfach für die Opfer von Genghis Khan, für die Opfer von Nero. Was ist denn mit Alexander dem Großen? Stolpersteine und dann einfach mal die ganze Welt voll Stolpersteine ballern. Und Denkmäler, also Holocaust-Denkmäler.
Sodass man sich kaum noch bewegen kann.
Ja, mega unpraktikabel, mega nervig.
Oder dass man die Decken alle so ein bisschen niedriger macht.
Einfach mal alle Decken in allen Häusern so 50 cm niedriger, dass man es so immer merkt.
So ein leichtes Gefühl der Enge hat auch vielleicht.
Ja.
Spart auch viel, du kannst auch mehr Wohnungen bauen einfach wahrscheinlich, so Zwischenetagen, wie in Björn-Jomelkiewicz. Finde ich nicht so schlecht. Finde ich gut. Wollen wir das mal einreichen? Wo reicht man sowas ein? Wo reicht man generell Ideen ein? Gibt es ein Stolperstein-Emoji? Ich wäre gerne dafür, nein, es gibt ein Stein-Emoji, wenn es hochkommt. Ich bin gerne dafür, dass man einfach mal so Ideen, so einen Ideen-Checker hat. Einfach, wo man im Internet, das heißt Ide, und da kannst du einfach deine Idee eintippen und dann sagt dir, gibt's das schon oder gibt's das nicht, wie groß sind die Chancen, dass du da wirklich durchkommst und wo muss ich mich dafür melden. Kann man die Seite i.de nennen? Ja, finde ich gut. Idee. Gibt's das schon, i.de? Ja, Check Domain. Die Domain wurde von einem Check Domain-Kunden registriert und befindet sich derzeit im Aufbau. Ja, seit 20 Jahren. Da hat jemand einfach das gesamte Alphabet an Domains gesichert und will jetzt richtig Cash dafür haben. Ja, eine gute Idee. Idee. Idee, Idee, Idee. Toll. Ja, das wäre so die Idee. Einfach ein Ideenchecker. Ich glaube, Patentamt ist eine gute Idee von einem Ideenchecker. Ja, ist eine gute Idee. Wo liegt das Patent fürs Patentamt? Hat sich das jemand patentiert? Im ersten Patentamt wahrscheinlich. So die erste Akte aller Zeiten. Die erste Akte, die in dem Patentamt. Machen wir so auf, so einen Spiegel. Ich, ich selbst. Darüber steht so, du bist das wahre Patent. Du bist einzigartig. Niemand kann dich kopieren. Okay, so emotional. Emotional das Patentamt. Eine gute Idee. Schlank. Die Emojis müssen wir auch mal machen. Nächste Woche Emoji-Pitch. Vielleicht finden wir irgendeinen besonderen Anlass für die Emojis. Was ist Emoji-Tag? Ist zufällig nächste Woche der Tag der Emojis? Ja, oder sowas wie eine besondere Podcast-Folge vielleicht. Das, weil wir machen ja immer die selben Podcast-Folgen. Vielleicht machen wir mal was Besonderes. Hey, aber was könnte man Besonderes machen für eine Folge Podcast? Wie will man das denn anders mal machen? Ich kann mir das nur vorstellen, wie wir hier einsam in unserem Raum sitzen und das machen. Nein, wir sind auf jeden Fall in unserem Raum und auch nur wir zu zweit. Aber irgendwas anderes oder vielleicht vielleicht, wir müssen noch mal nachdenken. Wir haben ganz viel Einsendung bekommen zum Thema Riechen und Geruch und ich möchte es einfach mal zusammenfassen, weil wir haben viel Mail bekommen, vielen Dank. Aber wir hatten beide so ein bisschen recht. Und zwar habe ich behauptet, dass Geschmack durch Luft übertragen wird und du hast gesagt, nein, das stimmt nicht, es wird im Kopf übertragen. Und es ist beides richtig, es wird im Kopf über Luft übertragen, über Geruch. Das heißt, du riechst nicht nur Nase vorne rum, sondern du riechst auch hinten rum, dass wenn du was isst, dass dann da irgendwie die Geschmacksgedöns aufsteigt, hinten rum über den Gaumen. Und wenn man erkältet ist, dann schmeckt man das nicht so gut und es ist richtig. Die Nase ist der Aromapparat, kann man sagen, oder? Ja. Der AA. Und der Aromapparat, der kann quasi das Detifrieren, egal von außen oder von innen, kann quasi das, was der Mund aufnimmt, dekodieren und dem Gehirn weitergeben als, so ist das. Und da gibt es auch noch einige, also wir haben einen Weinexperten, jemanden in der Ausbildung zu einem Weinkenner, Connoisseur macht und der hat gesagt, da gibt es auch Kontroversen, was denn auf der Zunge alles ist. Und zwar gibt es da dann bitter, irgendwie salzig, süss und dann gibt es Umami, was so viel wie wohlschmeckend bedeutet. Aber da streiten sich, da gibt es Kontroversen darüber, ob das wirklich existiert auf der Zunge. Es sind Kriege, es sind Kriege darüber ausgebrochen, über dieses Thema. Was ich interessant finde, dass es darum noch Kontroversen gibt, über solche grundlegenden Dinge des menschlichen Körpers. Aber mir scheint da, als hätten wir so eine Ader aufgestossen, zufällig. Wir haben ein bisschen gegraben in unserem Halbwissen und haben plötzlich so eine Leitung angestochen. Weil so viele Leute haben uns geschrieben, die offensichtlich in der Lebensmittelindustrie leben. Ich glaube, das ist in Deutschland einfach ein Thing. Leute arbeiten da und Leute sind Wissenschaftler. Und die haben auch nicht die ganze Zeit nichts zu tun, die können Podcast hören. Die stehen dann im Labor und du kannst halt nur dreimal am Tag essen. Ja, die testen die ganze Zeit Joghurt. Aromen sind der eigentliche Geschmack. Bei Erkältung schmeckt man nicht so viel.
Ja, echt spannend.
Also wir haben da, ich habe auch eine Handy-Nummer bekommen von einer Wissenschaftlerin.
Also wir können da mal gerne anrufen, wenn wir noch ein paar Ideen haben.
Aber ansonsten, du wurdest hart kritisiert für deine Milchaussage, dass Milch nach Wasser schmeckt. Wo ich mir auch denke, harte Milch-Fans.
Ich mache keine Gags mehr einfach. Ich versuche, weil es könnte ja wissenschaftlich falsch sein. Es ist zu ernst mittlerweile. Ja, ich habe auch überlegt, was wollt ihr denn? Wollt ihr, dass ich faktisch richtig, was wollt ihr lieber? Einen okayen Gag, wo man ein bisschen sich aus dem Fenster lehnt und ein bisschen eine kontroverse These aufstellt? Oder wollt ihr einfach einen knallharten, fakten-treuen Dude hier sitzen haben? Bei Milch verstehen die Leute keinen Spaß. Nee. Ich habe letztens ein Paket bekommen, kam hier an. Paket, großes Paket, schwer. Und jeder weiß, schwere Pakete sind die besten Pakete. Weil alle guten Sachen sind schwer. Das Gegenteil von Leuten, die bei DHL arbeiten, glaube ich. Absolut. Leichte Pakete sind die besten Pakete. Je schlecht gelaunter der Postmann ist, desto besser ist der Kunde gelaunt. Und dickes, schweres Paket. Ich dachte mir, wow, was ist das? Mache ich auf fünf Ausgaben einer meeresbiologischen wissenschaftlichen Zeitschrift, die ich bekomme. Die habe ich nicht bestellt. Da war kein Zettel dabei. Ich weiß nicht, ist es ein Gag, weil wir mal über Lagunen und Atolle geredet haben, aber da geht es dann über die Zukunft des Meeres irgendwie, das Meer wird kaputt gemacht, Fische werden abgefischt und irgendwie alles sauer wird alles und alles wird schlecht. Aber ich weiß nicht, was das ist. Ist das jetzt ein Gag? Ist das wirklich, weil ich bestelle relativ viel über Amazon, ob man da auch mal falsche Sachen bekommt einfach? Soll ich das jetzt jemandem sagen? Hallo, ich habe hier was Falsches bekommen? Kann ich nie sagen. Naja, vielleicht habe ich ja das bekommen statt, was ich bestellt habe und dann bekomme ich das nicht. Also vielleicht ist es, ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe auch keine Ahnung. Es ist schon spannend, wo man her, ich glaube, es war ein Fan, der uns darauf aufmerksam machen wollte, dass wir uns ein bisschen weiterbilden sollten, was unsere Marine, unser marines Wissen angeht, glaube ich. Ja, also auf jeden Fall, ich bin jetzt ein großer Experte. Ja, gut, dass das Thema nie wieder vorkommt, wahrscheinlich. Ja, absolut. Und einer aus meiner Familie darf sich dieses Weihnachten über fünf Meereszeitschriften freuen. Du liebst doch das Meer. Hab ich nie geliefert. Einmal am Urlaub. Weihnachtengeburtstag. Oh, Weihnachten, das ist schon Geschenke? Ey, Geschenke. Es gibt nichts Besseres, das würde einfach klar sagen, was sie wollen. Wie gesagt, ich sag's jedes Jahr. Ich hole mir eine Trompete dieses Jahr, einfach knallhart Trompete, um Posaunenspielen zu lernen. Das beste Geschenk, das man Leuten machen kann, ist, sich von ihnen etwas zu wünschen. Weil das Schlimmste an Weihnachten ist, dass man nicht weiß, was man anderen schenkt. Deswegen wünscht euch einfach Sachen, damit tut ihr euren Liebsten was Gutes und ihr bekommt auch ein Geschenk, das okay ist. Und ich meine im Grunde... Ist Weihnachten nicht auch irgendwann vorbei? Nein, nein, nein, ich bin großer Weihnachten-Fan. Ich bin großer Weihnachten-Fan. Schönen Lebkuchen. Ey, wir haben heute ironisch Last Christmas gesungen. Und dieser Song hat eine Magie, dass er gleichzeitig brutal nervt, aber er schafft es tatsächlich, eine Weinungsstimmung zu erzeugen. Weil solche Stimmungen kommen durch Leid. Durch, oh fuck, ich glaube, man verbindet viel mehr Emotionen mit negativen Dingen als mit positiven. Und wenn du so einen nervigen Song hörst, der auch so halb guilty pleasure, halb ich hasse ihn wirklich, hört mal auf jetzt, glaube ich, dadurch erzeugt du viel mehr Weihangstimmung, als wenn du es in Spiegel auskommst. Traditionen sind für Vollidioten, für komplette Vollidioten. Und es ist immer Abwechslung, weiss man vielleicht am Anfang nicht zu schätzen, mit dem Laufe der Zeit, lernst du das Prinzip, das Konzept der Abwechslung zu schätzen. Ich glaube, wenn wir einfach alle sagen, komm jetzt, das war, wir haben genug Ostern gehabt, wir haben genug Weihnachten gehabt, so. Jetzt mal Schluss damit, wir schenken uns erst mal an anderen Tagen, im Sommer was Schönes, einfach und so. Und übrigens an Geburtstagen schenkt man sich nicht mehr was, man muss anderen was schenken. Einfach mal ein bisschen Abwechslung reinbringen. So einen neuen Tapetenanstrich. Mal schön einfach mal Weihnachten zeigen lassen. Einfach mal Tapete drüber. Das ist vorbei. Einfach Tapete drüber. Es reicht auch langsam. Ey, holst du dir einen Weihnachtsbaum? Nein. Ich glaube, da, wo du Weihnachten feierst, hast du einen Weihnachtsbaum. Ja, klar. In meiner Heimat schon. Hilfst du dann aktiv mit, den zu beschmücken? Da wird der natürlich geschmückt. Ich bin immer der, der oben dann diesen Weihnachtstein draufsetzen muss. Aber guck mal, und was du für ein Lächeln gerade auf dem Mond hast. Das ist Tradition, das ist Weihnachten. Ja, ist auch ein bisschen nervig. Immer dieses Stefan! Stefan! Kannst du den Weihnachtstein drauf machen? So, das reicht doch mal irgendwann. Ja, aber das gehört mit dazu.
Ich freue mich tatsächlich jedes Jahr auf das Krippenspiel in der Kirche.
Das ist wirklich das Beste, jedes Jahr auf neue Meisterleistungen.
Alle sind genervt, ich gucke mich dann immer gerne um, ich drehe mich dann auch mal in der Bank um und gucke so Grinsen den Leuten ins Gesicht.
Immer pure Verachtung, Hassendes, die Leute finden es ganz schlimm und wollen am liebsten rausgehen, eine rauchen und dann irgendwann wiederkommen und dann noch die Hostie mitnehmen und nach Hause gehen. Und ich sitze da, wenn die denken, ich freue mich auf das Krippenspiel. Wie geil, jedes Jahr auch so geil. Immer neue inszenatorische, tolle Ideen. Oh, wer ist dieses Jahr? Durch wen wird dieses Jahr die Geschichte erzählt? Was ist die erzählt, perspektive dieses Jahr? Gibt es einen Voice-Over-Narrarrator, der schlecht nicht nach einem Blackfacing oder dieses Jahr dann doch nicht mehr? Was ist das erste Jahr, wo nicht der Julian geblackfaced wird?
Genau. Und dann ist es, weil die Julia, die offensichtlich allergisch ist gegen dieses Blackface im Mittel.
Naja, und dann letztes Jahr wurde halt durch einen Schmetterling die Weihnachtsgeschichte erzählt.
Eine fragwürdige narratorische Idee, ein Kniff, der vielleicht nicht ganz aufgegangen ist.
Naja, aber das nicht ganz aufgegangen ist.
Naja, aber das sind tolle Ideen.
Wird es mal vielleicht sogar unchronologisch erzählt?
So Tarantino-Style, Tarantino-Krippenschichte?
Mit Talking Heads oder so,
wo dann vorne Julian steht.
Also ich fand, dieses Jahr hat sich Jesus echter Leben benommen.
Da ist auch noch viel Möglichkeit.
Deswegen freue ich mich jedes Jahr aufs Neue.
Wie endet das eigentlich? Dann gehen alle wieder und dann ... Ja, passt jetzt. Applaus. Ach so. Das steht auch im Text drin. Ich glaube, Applaus kommt daraus, die peinliche Stille nach Aktionen verhindern zu wollen. Irgendwann war es allen unangenehm und haben alle überlegt, wie können wir jetzt maximal viel Lärm erzeugen, um das Gegenteil von der peinlichen Stille zu machen. Okay, haben wir an sich rumgeklopft und dann war auch schnell das Klatschen da. Ja, vielleicht hat man sich aneinander geklatscht. War so ein Rumpeln. Ja, es war eher ein Rumpeln. Vielleicht hat es alle aufges... weil früher mussten die ja übereinander sitzen, weil ja ganz wenig Platz war im Gaukler-Zelt. Und dann werden alle aufstehen und mir einfach einfach gerumpelt. Einfach schön draufgesetzt. Wir haben auf so einem Berner draufgesetzt. Einfach schön auf so einem Haufen. Da war auch kein Stühl rein, das war ein Menschenhaufen, wo sich die Leute einfach dann draufgelegt haben und dann gehofft haben, noch was zu sehen. Das Prinzip des Stuhls wurde auch viel zu spät erfunden. Viel zu spät. Gab es erst den Rollstuhl oder erst das Rad? Mit Rollstuhl meinst du, das Rhönrad, wo man so komplett drin ist und sagt, das macht schon Spaß, aber mir wird schlecht. Erst so Rad, vielleicht erst so hingelegt. Ich glaube, ich bin einer der ersten Menschen, die einen Gyrocopter sich holen. Was ist ein Gyrocopter? Richtig, das gibt es, einen Mannhelikopter, wo du überall fliegen darfst. Ich kann einfach zu Hause bei mir aufsteigen, fliegen und hier bei der Arbeit wieder landen. Und dann lande ich hier und bin innerhalb von fünf Minuten überall. Du meinst so ein bisschen wie dein Boosted Board? Nee, in der Luft halt. Wie oft hast du das verwendet, dein Boosted Board? In der Luft und weniger gefährlich. Jetzt gerade im Winter ist es ein bisschen schwierig, ne? Mit dem ganzen Schotter auf dem Boden. Es ist glatt und Schnee überall und es ist Eis und überall ist mehr Schotter. Weil Leute sind noch die Idee gekommen, okay, wir machen es nochmal Winterfest, hau nochmal den Schotter raus. Schotter ist der grösste Feind des Boosted-Boot-Fahrers. Was passiert mit dem ganzen Schotter, der zu Weihnachten, der wird wieder aufgesammelt eigentlich? Ja. Schon, da kommen dann diese Besen, Besen,en, Entschuldigung, diese Besengeräte, die dann den ganzen Schotter wieder aufsammeln, oder? Ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, was mit Schotter jetzt genau meins. Aber Straße? Ja, halt dieses Streu. Schneestreu. Wie heißt das denn? Salz. Schnee. Nee, halt dieses Steinchen. Kiesel. Nee. Kieselstreu. Komm, du weißt, was ich meine. Steinchen auf die Straße, damit man nicht ausrückt. Wo streut man denn Steinchen? Hast du Schaden? Im Winter, wenn es glatt ist, streut man Steinchen. Ich habe ein neues. Verniedlichungen zu brüllen, ist toll. Was meinst du mit den scheiß Steinchen? Steinerle. Bring doch wieder die Nüsschen, habe ich gesagt. Aber kannst du mir erklären, warum man im Winter Salz streut? Ja, weil Salz Feuchtigkeit entzieht und Schnee zu Eis macht. Aber wo kommt die Feuchtigkeit hin? Entschuldigung, Wasser macht, sorry. Aber wo kommt die Feuchtigkeit hin, die das Salz entzieht? Da, wo auch Regen hinkommt. Gulli. Aber ich bin jetzt Doktor Salz und ich nehme das Wasser. Und wo tue es hin? Nee, du, ja. Ich löse mich doch in Wasser auf. Ja, ja. Aber du entziehst Wasser in dich auf und löst ihn auf. Aber ist es nicht so, dass es den Gefrierpunkt raufsetzt und somit schmilzt es dann ab? Ja, genau, das ist auch ein Ding. Salz Wasser friert ja auch wann anders. Genau, weil wenn du kochendes Wasser hast und Salz reintust, dann hört es auf zu kochen. Voll, sofort. Weil es ein Siedepunkt raufsetzt. Weil es weiss, jetzt kommen die Nudeln, ich höre mal kurz auf, zu kochen, damit er die Nudeln reinmachen kann. Boah, mir war so dermaßen schlecht die letzten zwei Tage. Ich dachte mir, ich hatte einen Tag, die Hälfte des Tages frei und dachte mir, weißt du was, nutze die Zeit mal und kochst mal was Schönes. Und kochst. Mal richtig schön kochen. Was habe ich gekocht? Spaghetti Agliaglio. Schön Knoblauch und Oliven. Also wirklich, meine Wohnung stinkt immer noch nach Knoblauch und ich glaube, ich habe viel zu viel Olivenöl genommen. Mir war so brutal schlecht danach, weil ich glaube, ich einfach einen halben Liter Olivenöl geäxt habe, mehr oder weniger. Es war so fucking ölig. Und ich habe mir Tutorials angeguckt, wie man das kocht. Und wirklich, wenn du denkst, unter irgendwie den Videos, die du normalerweise konsumierst, werden heftige und beleidigende Kommentare gepostet. Schau dir mein Koch-Tutorial an. Gute Nacht, Johanna. Du verdammtes Mongo-Arschloch-Klubbauch-Fan 31. Ich kann nicht fassen, was du gerade gesagt hast. Da gehören zwei Esslöffel Salz. Bella Italia 28, ich schneide dir die Lymphknoten raus. Vor allem auch dieses, tut man Salz in das Nudelwasser, tut man Olivenöl ins Nudelwasser.
Jamie Oliver sagt und auch Gordon Ramsay sagen beide, sowohl Salz als auch Olivenöl soll man in Nudelwasser tun. Aber die Kommentare, ich bin Italiener und bei uns macht man das anders. Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, unglaublich hasserfüllte und aggressive Kommentare. Vor allem, ich würde gerne mal, also, ich versuche ja, ich bin großer Fleischfan oder Steakfan. Und versuche seit Jahren, das perfekte Steak in der perfekten ... Mal selber zu checken, wann ist es genau medium rare, wann habe ich es genau so, wie ich es mag und so. Und dann gibt es ja so Tipps wie, das Steak muss erst auf Zimmertemperatur sein, nicht aus dem Kühlschrank direkt in die Pfanne hauen. Dann gibt es diese in der Pfanne erst, dann Backofen, 15 Minuten. Manche sagen gar nicht Backofen, manche sagen nur Backofen, manche sagen kurz anbraten, manche sagen ein bisschen länger anbraten, dann gibt es diese 90-90-90 Idee, wo man dann halt das 90 Sekunden lang anbrät, dann dreht um 90 Grad, um auch ein cooles Muster drin zu haben, nochmal dreht, einmal dann komplett dreht und dann Backofen macht und so weiter und so fort. Tatsächlich komme ich aber nie dazu, überhaupt mal zwei Dinge zu vergleichen, weil dann andere Variablen wieder, irgendwas funktioniert nicht. Dann hast du halt diese eine Variable mal ausprobiert mit, das eine lasse ich mal auf Zimmertemperatur, das andere hole ich mal direkt aus dem Kühlschrank, aber dann ist der Backofen nicht richtig vorgehalten. Die Chance, dass alle Variablen exakt so sind, dass du weißt, aha, also wer hat das immer ausprobiert? Da muss so viel Arbeit reinfließen. Und da denke ich mir auch so, nee, komm, jetzt einfach so. Ja, es stimmt und es vergeht auch viel Zeit zwischen den verschiedenen Probephasen, sodass man die Kritik nicht gut umsetzen kann. Mein Ziel war es, die beste Süsskartoffelsuppe der Welt zu machen. Und dann habe ich verschiedene Rezepte ausprobiert und ich habe dann immer tatsächlich ein Dokument, das finde ich jetzt leider nicht, kann ich vielleicht mal aussuchen, ein Dokument, und habe dann jedes Mal gemacht, genau das habe ich verwendet, genauso meine Zubereitung und das ist mein Fazit, beim nächsten Mal mehr Zwiebeln. Dann habe ich das gelesen und beim nächsten Mal dann mehr Zwiebeln gemacht, habe genau aufgeschrieben, diesmal zwei Zwiebeln mehr. Und dann geschrieben... Ja, aber du vergisst meistens, wie es war, weil es so lange her ist. Nee, ich habe es genau aufgeschrieben, Deswegen habe ich mich durchgearbeitet und ich bin auch wirklich an den Punkt gekommen, wo ich finde, dass sie sehr gut geworden ist. Irgendwann hat der einfach keinen Bock mehr drauf, weil ich immer das sehr gegessen habe. Und ich habe jetzt zwar die perfekte Süßkartoffelsuppe, aber ich habe keinen Bock mehr drauf. Aber meine Herangehensweise an Kochen ist immer, ich schaue mir das Video an, aber ich schreibe mir nichts auf und gehe dann einkaufen und versuche es nach dem Gedächtnis nachzukochen, so dass ich mir selber Gedanken machen muss, wie viele Knoblauchzehen jetzt nochmal und dann dass man es so ein bisschen ausprobiert, weil genau nachkochen nach dem Rezept finde ich doof, weil dann hast du da keine Beziehung zu dem Essen. Es könnte dem Urwerden. Du hast keine Beziehung zu dem Essen und du weißt auch nicht genau, was genau ist jetzt das, wenn du es aber selber noch mal rekonstruierst.
Ja, ich würde fast sagen, koch einfach wie Gordon Ramsay das sagt. Der hat da schon ein bisschen rumprobiert, der hat vielleicht auch mal so Dokumente angelegt, wo er sich überlegt hat, was es besser machen könne. Einfach nach dem Kochen. Beziehung zum Essen ist Bullshit. Hast du diesen Ausstand gesehen von Jamie Oliver, wo er wieder Schüler gekocht hat?
Er ging auch so ein bisschen rum als virales Video, wo er dann so
die Kinder essen immer nur Junkfood
und Fastfood und er wollte mal zeigen, was denn da
wirklich drin ist. Wo er den Kindern
Chicken Nuggets zeigt und dann so
Küken auch raspelt und dann
danach am Ende die Frage stellt, so
und wer würde von euch jetzt nochmal die Chicken Nuggets
essen? Und die Kinder nach einer kurzen Pause,
weil sie nicht wissen, was er erwartet wird für eine Antwort.
Ja, wir, alle!
Und er hat einfach,
er hat die Frage vielleicht ein bisschen doof formuliert. Alle Kinder
Vielen Dank. und die Kinder nach einer kurzen Pause, weil sie nicht wissen, was er erwartet wird, für eine Antwort. Ja, wir, alle! Und er hat einfach, er hat die Frage vielleicht ein bisschen doof formuliert. Alle Kinder wollten danach. Ja, genau das habe ich mir nämlich auch gedacht. Aus welcher Motivation heben die Kinder jetzt die Hand? Wollen die das jetzt wirklich essen oder sind die es einfach immer nur gewohnt? Ja. Wieso wie im Kasperletheater? Ja, ja, exakt das war es. Und er will den Kasperle sehen, ja, aber das ist jetzt keine... Niemand erwartet ein Nein von Kindern. Das ist jetzt keine echte Äußerung ihrer Meinung, sondern es ist halt einfach konditioniert. Wenn du um Kasperle-Theater fragen würdest, und soll Kasperle den bösen Mann umbringen und den tausend Einzelteile zerhacken, ja, ja, ja, dann würde er Nein sagen. Kinder sind nicht auch konditioniert, ja zu rufen. Weil einerseits, finde ich, war seine Strategie schlecht von Jamie Oliver, weil jetzt nur, weil du das Hühnchenfleisch pürierst, was jetzt natürlich für, sag ich mal, Leute, die schon viel Gäste... Das hat schon so, äh, ausgelöst. Aber die Idee von Frittieren ist doch, dass du am Ende nicht mehr siehst, wie ekelhaft das ursprüngliche Gericht war. Und das funktioniert. Wenn du Chicken Nuggets vor dir hast oder irgendwas, was gefrittiert wurde, scheißegal. Und die Kinder sehen das frittierte, goldbraun, knusprig gefrittierte und sagen, ja klar will ich das essen, weil es gut aussieht. Die vergessen doch, was da drin ist und das ist auch egal. Und vor allem, dass Essen eklig aussieht, kann doch nicht das Argument dafür sein, dass es schlechtes Essen ist. Es gibt viel Essen, das eklig aussieht, aber trotzdem gesund und lecker ist. Er hat ja auch so ein bisschen versucht, er hätte auch schon diese Hühnchen klein gemacht und das war schon alles ziemlich widerlich aus. Er hat es auch schön anschaulich widerlich gemacht und ich glaube, da haben die Kinder ja auch viele gemacht und dann war die Frage einfach doof. Die Fragestellung war, und wer will jetzt noch essen? Yay! Und es war auch so eine Dynamik, dass ich glaube, ein oder zwei Kinder haben als erstes die Hand gehoben und alle anderen Kinder reflexartig, instinktiv, oh, ich will nicht, dass der mehr bekommt als ich. Und dann wollen sie es auch haben. Wenn einer was will, wollen sie es alle auch haben. Das ist mega spannend, es gab ein Experiment mal, irgendwann in den, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich sage mal, acht, neunzigern? Okay, okay, immer schön ins 19. Jahrhundert. Okay, geil, geil. Naja, jedenfalls ist man, nee, ich erzähle mal kurz weiter und ihr könnt selber raten, warum das gerade wahrscheinlich falsch war. Und zwar ist man auch zu der Uni gegangen und hat gesagt, wollt ihr für Hot Dogs im Bestand Joes folgendes folgende Schild hochladen? Ihr kriegt auch ein iPhone. Also für Joes, für Joes Pizzeria oder Joes Hotdog-Stand, wollt ihr das Schild hochhalten. Und alle Leute, die Ja gesagt haben, hat man danach gefragt, was glaubst du, wie hätte die Mehrheit sich entschieden? Alle Leute, die gesagt haben, ja klar, würde ich machen, wenn ich ein bisschen Geld damit verdiene, easy, haben gedacht, so würde auch die Mehrheit entscheiden. Alle Leute, die Nein gesagt haben, haben gedacht, das würde auch die Mehrheit sagen. Also jeder hält seine Meinung für die Mehrheitsmeinung. Genau, das war halt so ein krasses Ding, krasse Erkenntnis damals in der Psychologie, weil alle Leute immer nach der Maxime handeln, von denen sie glauben, dass eh alle anderen das genauso machen würden. Ja, oder andersrum denken, dass sie denken, die Masse würde so handeln, wie sie selber handeln würde. Ja. Hm. Genau, da ist halt nicht ganz klar, was zuerst da ist, aber... Meinst du, das hat sich gewandelt?
Ich meine, gut, seit
1724 ist eine Menge Zeit vergangen,
weil es gibt doch diesen Spruch
die
Mehrheit
der Menschen hält sich für die
Minderheit oder
sowas. Also verstehst du, was ich meine? Dass man sagt,
die meisten Menschen sind dumm, die meisten
Menschen fallen auf Werbung rein
und die meisten Menschen denken, sie sind nicht
Vielen Dank. Minderheit. Oder sowas. Also verstehst du, was ich meine? Dass man sagt, die meisten Menschen sind dumm, die meisten Menschen fallen auf Werbung rein und die meisten Menschen denken, sie sind nicht so dumm wie die anderen alle. Sie halten sich für, ja, ich glaube, so gut wie jeder Mensch würde die Aussage unterschreiben, die Masse der Menschen ist dumm. Aber damit meint man natürlich, naja, ich nicht so, sondern alle anderen. Das heißt, alle Menschen halten sich für einen kleinen Teil der Menschen. Und meinst du, es war vielleicht mal anders, dass es heute eher so durch diese Individualität, irgendwie jeder muss seinen eigenen Weg gehen, man muss sich von der Masse abheben, vielleicht ist es ein anderes Menschenmöglich. Es ist auch mittlerweile so, dass man gerne Meinungen hat und gerne andere Meinungen hat und das ganze Hipstertum und sowas. Ich meine, vielleicht war 1728 einfach eine andere Zeit, wo man eher... 1649 eine andere Zeit. Ja, ich glaube, wo einfach jeder für sich selbst man sich als Kollektiv verstanden hat, so irgendwie wir alle zusammen. Wir können die gewagte These ausstellen, dass 1548 einfach eine andere Zeit war. Ja. Würdest du da mitgehen? Ich glaube, es war einfach, ich glaube, es waren auch andere Menschen damals. Ja, die waren auch kleiner. Viel kleiner. Die sind mit 40 gestorben. Ich glaube, man hat irgendwann gedacht, crazy, was wir Menschen können. Wir sind schon ganz schön schlau, Menschen sind schon ganz schön schlau.
Tatsächlich sagen ja auch Leute, die nicht so schlau sind, eher, ich bin sehr schlau, als sehr schlaue Menschen sagen, ich bin sehr schlau, gefühlt. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen so ein Ding, dass man vielleicht jetzt, wo man weiss, was man kann und wie gefährlich Massen sind und so, tendenziell eher Abstand von solchen Aussagen nimmt und sich lieber mal ein bisschen Understatement betreibt als damals. Ich glaube, damals war der Mensch arroganter als Masse und hat sich mehr zugetraut als Masse. Vor allem so Krankheiten wie Alzheimer zum Beispiel gab es wahrscheinlich schon über die gesamte Menschheitsgeschichte, aber haben einfach keine Rolle gespielt, weil Menschen nicht so alt wurden.
Und irgendwann war der Lebensstandard so hoch, dass Menschen länger gelebt haben und plötzlich merkte, oh wow, es gibt hier Krankheit. Das ist der Fehler, den du immer machst, der uns andauern vorgehalten wird.
Leute wurden genauso alt, die Lebenserwartung war im Schnitt nur nicht so hoch, weil viele bei der Geburt gestorben sind.
Nein.
Menschen sind im Durchschnitt früher gestorben.
Natürlich sind die Leute, aber nicht so signifikant viel. Doch, auf jeden Fall. Die sind nicht 23 geworden. Es gab keine 80-Jährigen im Mittelalter. Ey, es gab locker 70-, 60-Jährige. Nein. Man spricht nur von einer geringen Lebenserwartung, weil Leute, weil der Kindstod total, wenige Leute sind halt alt geworden, weil die meisten einfach früh krepriert sind an Krankheiten, im Kindesalter. Der Durchschnittsalter ist deswegen nur 24, weil so viele im frühen Alter gestorben sind. Nein. Trotzdem gab es auch 80- und 60-Jährige. Nee. Okay, gut. Da muss ich dir jetzt wirklich widersprechen. Du, ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher, aber tatsächlich. Es gab natürlich auch mehr Kindstote und es gab mehr Tote früher, aber trotzdem, also ich weiß nicht, wie man das jetzt statistisch korrekt ausdrückt, mit durchschnittliches Todesalter oder sowas, aber die sind auf jeden Fall, die sind nicht so alt geworden. Naja, wenn man aber Leute anguckt, wie im Schnitt. Die älteste Generation war damals jünger. Ja. Als heute. Aber ich glaube nicht so signifikant, wie wir das immer. Doch, ich glaube schon. Also wenn man jetzt mal guckt, wie alt so Beethoven ist und die bekannten Namen werden.
Ja, welch alt sind die gestorben?
Luther ist auch 63 geworden immerhin.
Ja, 63?
Ja, und, aber das ist nicht ...
Das ist aber nochmal 20 Jahre jünger als ...
Wir haben hier mal einen Podcast aus ...
Luther?
Ich benutze nicht mein Gedächtnis.
Hier auch Beethoven, saftige 57 geworden. Ja mein Gott, das ist auch mal gut irgendwann. Und ich meine, das waren ja angesehene Mittlereine Leute. 65. Naja gut, vielleicht nicht ganz so krass. Vielleicht nicht ganz so krass, aber trotzdem waren sie jünger. Ich habe auf jeden Fall in dem Buch gelesen, dass Alzheimer eine junge diagnostizierte Krankheit ist, weil es früher einfach nicht so viele Rentner gab. Ich glaube, weil Leute dumm waren. Vielleicht weil die auch einfach das nicht gecheckt haben oder sich nicht leisten. Ja, ich glaube, weil die es nicht gecheckt haben. Ich glaube, weil es waren eh alle relativ dämlich und man war auch medizinisch nicht so weit. Und dann hat man halt mal Dinge vergessen, haben alle gesagt, ja gut, aber alle anderen vergessen auch Dinge und sind dumm. Wie kann man das mit einem Google-Begriff? Das Ding ist halt, dass du, wie willst du denn die Zahlen darstellen, wenn nicht als Durchschnitt? Du kannst doch nur von einer durchschnittlichen Lebenserwartung sprechen. Warum sollte man, also deswegen ist es halt so fragwürdig. Ich glaube, der Homo Sapiens wird halt, wir haben uns in den letzten 100 Jahren, hat der Mensch Homo Sapiens nur älter, weil, weil die Medizin besser ist und so weiter. Ja, das ist ja klar. Aber der Mensch, trotzdem besprechen wir ja nicht. Naja, auch so ein bisschen. Weil wir haben auch mal uns in so einem Bit in Rage geredet, haben gesagt, wie war das früher, als wir nur 14 Jahre alt wurden, hätten die theoretisch eine vernünftige Gesellschaft haben aufbauen können. Ja. Aber tatsächlich waren die mit 14 Jahren genauso wenig entwickelt und die Gehirne genauso wenig entwickelt wie heute 14-Jährige. Naja, es kommt darauf an, was du jetzt mit Gehirne entwickelt meinst. Ich glaube, also... Also das Gehirn entwickelt sich anders, wenn du ab sieben auf dem Feld arbeitest, als wenn du irgendwie mit acht eingeschult wirst und den ganzen Tag rumsitzt. Das ist halt ein anderes Gehirn einfach. Du kannst halt dann gut arbeiten. Ich meine jetzt rein biologisch. Ja, aber... Ich meine jetzt rein... Ja, es ist halt wirklich interessant. Was heißt denn biologisch? Ich meine, es ist ja... Entwickelt sich ja durch die Einflüsse. Auch. Ich meine, es wird nicht nur rein biologisch. Einfach, wann ist ein Gehirn ausgewachsen? Wann ist ein Gehirn, wann ist ein Mensch, ein Körper ausgewachsen? Und wann beginnt der Zerfall eines Körpers? Und ich glaube, da war das nicht anders. Ich glaube, wenn die damaligen 30-Jjährigen sahen aus wie unsere heutigen Dreissigjährigen, das ist meine These. Aber ist es nicht sogar, dass jetzt irgendwie Kinder auch früher in die Pubertät kommen? Wir haben uns jetzt vorwiegend von Lebensmitteln, wieder sind wir wieder bei der Evolution und jetzt ist halt wieder so ein Scheißthema, wir kriegen wieder Nachrichten und ach, was war die Frage? Ey komm, wir kriegen das auch alleine hin, ohne die Schwammintellass einfach... Hier, guck mal, ich hab hier einen Artikel der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Fake News. Die Pubertät beginnt immer früher. Wissenschaftler rätseln, liegt es an der Ernährung, am stressigen Leben oder woran sonst? Kinder kommen früher in die Pubertät. Und ich meine, das ist ja auch ein hormoneller Gehirnprozess, also kann man sagen, dass sie sich anders entwickeln als früher. Das ist das Gegenteil von der These, die wir ja da aufgestellt haben. Also früher hätte ja die Pubertät früher sein müssen, weil es ja das Leben kürzer ist. Du hast gesagt, dass es immer gleich ist. Ich habe gesagt, dass es variabel ist, was ja erstmal der erste Unterschied ist. Und jetzt habe ich meiner eigenen Richtung der Variabilität widersprochen, das ist richtig. Aber trotzdem, wir haben einfach, glaube ich, keine Ahnung, kann man sagen. Aber Luther, nur wo du einmal eine Sendung über Luther gesehen hast, denkst du, da hast du Ahnung über Luther. Das Lutherjahr. Ich habe mal Luther gegoogelt. Ich habe nur leider gehört, dass die Buchwirtschaft sehr enttäuscht war, dass das Lutherjahr so gefloppt ist. Die Buchindustrie, glaube ich, sagt man, die Buchwirtschaft. Alter, Rossini, 76 geworden. Ja, aber die waren auch super reich und die wurden dann halt gepflegt am Ende, aber so der durchschnittliche Mensch. Gepflegt am Ende. Du glaubst ja nicht dass so ein Bauer, der irgendwie bis 40 auf dem Feld arbeitet, und dann stirbt an Erschöpfung. Genau, richtig. Über die Gründe reden wir, wie gesagt, nicht. Wir reden darüber, dass es biologisch trotzdem dem Menschen eigentlich vorherbestimmt ist, dieses Leben zu leben. Ja, aber was heißt das eigentlich? Heute kannst du halt alle, den großen Teil der Krankheiten heilen, die ein Mensch eigentlich bekommt. Was soll denn eigentlich bedeuten? Komplett. Die a priori, um jetzt mal ins Lateinische zu wechseln, weil es ein bisschen besser klingt, ohne Einflüsse, in einem leeren Raum, in der Matrix, ist der Mensch dazu gemacht, hundert Jahre alt zu werden, meinetwegen?
Ja gut, aber was ist das für eine Aussage? Naja, in dem Moment wird es eine Aussage, wo man sagt, man nimmt Martin Luther und stellt ihn ebenfalls in die Matrix und lässt ihn da auch so ein Kram machen mit dem Buch. Aber du kannst einen Menschen doch nicht im luftleeren Raum betrachten, der muss doch irgendwas essen und der muss doch irgendwas atmen und der muss doch in irgendwas laufen. Ich rede ja nur von der genetischen Voraussetzung des Menschen. Wie lang ist der dazu bestimmt zu leben? Wie lang, wenn alles gut läuft? Ja, es ist halt schwer, weil der muss halt auch irgendwas essen. Dann lass halt einen Menschen heute mit einem Menschen von damals das exakt gleiche Leben leben. Das exakt gleiche Leben leben. Das ist ja genau dieses Versuchsratung, die ich gerade herstellen will. Mit dem Luftgelehr und dem Raum. Ja, dann würde ich natürlich auch sagen, dass die gleich alt werden. Sooo! Ja, aber das hat auch nie jemand wieder behauptet. Nee, nee, nee, doch, doch, du hast gerade ... Spür mal zurück. Ich habe gesagt, dass Menschen früher nicht so alt wurden, aber über die Gründe haben wir nie gesprochen. Das sind natürlich medizinische Gründe, ernährungsfähige Kriege, Krankheiten. Du hast gesagt, das ist variabel. Du hast auch eben mit deinem Pubertätsding auch eher sagen wollen, wie variabel das ist. Es ist schon nicht so einfach. Du wolltest schon Variabilität eigentlich sagen. Ich bin der Meinung, das hat sich nicht verändert. Grossartig, vielleicht ein bisschen. Ja, aber auch da hängt es ja von äusseren Einflüssen an. Wie die Ernährung. Die kannst du ja nicht loswerden. Ja. Lass es mal aufstehen. Lass es mal generell. Ich finde, dieses Sitzen immer. Einmal mal aufstehen. Ich finde dieses Sitzen immer, einfach mal aufstehen ein bisschen. Wir können einen kleinen Spaziergang machen. Ja genau, zwei Meter Radius, weil die Kabel dann vorbei sind. Guck mal, hier sind zwei Stühle aufeinander gestapelt und ich setze mich jetzt oben drauf. Ey, das ist immer gefährlich. Das ist gefährlich. Boah, ich sitze hoch. Ich sitze richtig hoch. Sind alle Stühle gleich hoch eigentlich? Gibt es da eine normierte Höhe? Es gibt tatsächlich Treppennormen. Oh ja, das ist aber wichtig. Es ist halt wichtig, weil es gibt eine Treppe irgendwo, ich weiß nicht genau, ob es steht, Berlin oder so oder Abu Dhabi, ich habe echt keine Ahnung, da ist eine Treppe halt ein bisschen grösser und eine Treppenstufe und alle Leute, die da langlaufen, stolpern immer über diese eine Treppe. Und dann haben Leute mal angefangen, da Kameras aufzustellen,
weil denen aufgefallen ist, Moment, irgendwas ist so strange, haben sie nachgemessen tatsächlich zwei Zentimeter zu hoch, diese eine Treppenstufe. Und der wird jetzt komplett Gold eingefärbt. Die wird Gold eingefärbt und mit Blumenfeld draufgeschrieben. Stolperstufe. Stehen ist doof. Ja, stehen ist wirklich do durch. Ach ja.
Guck mal, du hast ja noch Jaffer-Cakes von letzter Woche.
Wollen wir die Story gleich wieder auf?
Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Metapher für unseren Podcast.
Die vor einer Woche aufgemachten Jaffer-Cakes, die jetzt trocken und verdorben dastehen.
Wollen wir das nochmal aufmachen?
Das ist genau der Podcast Inner Plastik Shell. Ja, nicht schlecht. Guckt euch mal bitte die Dokumentation an, Jim and Andy. Jetzt auf Netflix geht um Jim Carrey, wie er bei dem Film Man on the Moon von Milos Forman die ganze Zeit in Character war. Es ist eine Man on the Moon, it's the Man on the Moon. Und es ist tatsächlich eine der besten Dokumentationen, die ich in meinem ganzen Leben je gesehen habe. Wie viele Dokumentationen hast du in deinem Leben gesehen? Zwei Stück. Gut. Und die ist wirklich so, ich habe geweint, ich habe gelacht, ich habe zurückgespult, weil ich Szenen nicht glauben konnte. Ich habe gestern den Film Man on the Moon geguckt, und jetzt kann ich die Dokumentation noch weniger glauben. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, ich glaube die ist noch grösser als ich die zunächst schon eingeschätzt habe, es ist einfach ein Kunstwerk, schaut euch bitte erste Dokumentation an, auch wenn es unterintiv erscheint, und dann den Film, macht das bitte alle, und dann können wir nächste Woche darüber sprechen. Okay, dann mal eine Hausaufgabe ... Genau, mal eine Hausaufgabe aufgeben. Wenn wir ein bisschen zusammen auf einem Stand sind,
können wir anfangen zu reden.
Jim and Andy auf Netflix, Dokumentation könnt ihr überall
anders streamen, und danach den Film Man on the Moon. Geht um den Comedian und ein großes Vorbild für uns beide, obwohl wir den nicht so richtig bewusst wahrgenommen haben, seine Kunst, immer schon irgendwie geworshipped haben offensichtlich auf unserem ... Durch Stellvertreter. Ja, auf eine Art haben wir so ein bisschen sein Werk weitergetragen.
Mega unbewusst und es ist sehr arrogant zu behaupten.
Aber das ist schon ganz schön interessant.
Und wir haben unterbewusst immer seine Meinung vertreten,
auch in allen nädlichen Diskussionen, die wir jemals mit Redakteuren und so hatten.
Also ganz, ganz tolle Sache und auch für uns und für den Podcast und für euch bestimmt mega interessant in der Hinsicht.
Von daher, das wäre eine coole Ausaufgabe, wenn wir das alle machen könnten,
dann können wir nächste Woche gut drüber reden.
Cool.
Damit entlassen wir euch in die Vorweihnachtszeit und wünschen euch
ganz viel Spaß und viel Erfolg.
Ohne Scheiß, wollen wir mal
vielleicht den Adventskalender revolutionieren?
Gibt es da eine Idee? Irgendwas?
Okay, alles klar, dann macht einfach ab dem 1.
12. fangt ihr an mit der Grenze.
Ciao, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal,
wir heben ab und sagen